دراما رمضان 2023 وتحديدا مسلسل جعفر
العمده سلطه الضوء على ما يعرف باسم الخلع
الامريكاني وهو رفع الزوجه قضيه للطلاق عن
طريق الخلع وتتم عمليه اخطار زوجها على
عنوان خاطئ ما يجعله لا يعرف بالقضيه او
حتى بحدوث الطلاق من سبع شهور
ما دفع البرلمان للتحرك لضمان حق الزوج في
معرفه ما يجري والدفاع عن نفسه امام
القاضي
فقد طلب عضون في البرلمان احاطه لمجلس
النواب المصري بخصوص هذه المساله اوضح فيه
ان هذا النوع من الخلع واللجوء الزوجه بعد
الخلع الزواج من شخص اخر يمثل هدم الاسره
المصريه ويؤدي لتفكيكها مقترحا ان يحتوي
مشروع قانون الاسره الجديد الجاري اعداده
حاليا على ضوابط جديده لمساله الخلع
بالقانون وان يكون الخلع بحضور الزوج او
موكله امام القاضي وان لا يتم في غياب
احدهما ويقدم الزوج دوافعه امام المحكمه
ليحكم القاضي في النهايه ما اذا كان من
حقها الخلع ام لا كما اقترح ان يتم اخطار
الزور عن طريق وسائل الاتصال الحديثه حتى
تتيقن المحكمه من ان اعلان الوصول قد تحقق
الزوج عن الحضور او توكيل محامي عن خلال
مده ينص عليها القانون يتم السير في
الاجراءات القانونيه للخلع بشكل طبيعي
[موسيقى]